hello everyone I'm alone I loved my
channel right before we get into this
video which is about dude who might have
been confirmed to be around someone has
coronavirus who wants to find a date who
has been in the same situation so that
they can quarantine together which Wow I
thought that I would give you a quick
intro to what you're watching this is
basically a highlights exit from the
full show that I just wanted to release
early full episode of this podcast which
for anyone who doesn't know is a Miskin
it what other way misconnections comedy
storytelling podcast available every
month now who is going to be the first
episode will be up on April 10th on
pretty much all audio services and yeah
it's basically a show we like hunt down
really weird stories on Craigslist or
reddit and discuss them and make fun of
them and have a good time for this
particular episode we are joined by Ross
from the game grumps and the person
who's going to be my regular cohost who
is Ethan Esther who some of you might
know as crank gameplays but yeah I'm
kind of dropping this one really hot
because I figured people need some more
positive like how-to entertainment in
their world right now
we were waiting on sponsors but screw it
so enjoy this was on I believe Ally
which i think is maybe Bay Area
Craigslist hmm
it says quarantine King looking for
Corona Queen I got a Sam's card
what's the Sam's card Sam's Club is
Walmart's like it's kind of like Costco
but Walmart okay right it says I got a
Sam's card I got plenty of hand wipes
paper towels and a swipe hot tub and
personal gym so this is this dude like
explaining what he has in his apartment
I'm 59 years old normal in nearly every
good way whatever that means
I'm awaiting a coronavirus test result
for a friend not my test but if my
friend tests positive I will need to
start 14 day quarantine so this dude is
setting this up by saying I have a dope
apartment mm-hmm one of my friends seems
like he's gonna have coronavirus which
means that I might have it so I'm gonna
need a 14 day cream what but I gotta
know the section apartment though so
primeval
urghhh tells me if I go into 14-day
quarantine I need a likewise primeval
urging partner you being normal healthy
fun age-appropriate sexy female for a
likes it's the end of the world big bang
quarantine this is real wash your hands
good luck what does he mean by big bang
big attack once man is done it's been
like I'm gonna have to quarantine for 14
days maybe there's someone else out
there who is forcibly quarantine him
because their friend also maybe has
coronavirus so they've been traveling so
what if we just quarantine together I
got a hot tub okay dad what if this
happened and they fell it like that
would be such a great love story of like
yeah we met because of is this reddit or
Craigslist what is it this one was on
Craigslist Craigslist because of a
Craigslist ad because like my boyfriend
needed to be quarantined for 14 days so
did I
okay health-wise concerning because I
mean if you're quarantined for the 14
days the whole point is you're not
supposed to be with someone else yes if
they feel he's not taking the dressed
himself if he tested positive then I
would understand searching for someone
else who's also tested positive so like
if he was like I got coronavirus I'm
gonna chill at home do you have karna
virus come to my hot tub I have paper
towels and a swipe still not sure if
he's referring to toilet paper or he's
dancing around it because he missed out
on toilet paper we'll figure it out I
mean many questions but if he is just
cour attaining because one of his
friends is positive for coronavirus
inviting someone else who maybe has to
do the same thing around is a bad idea
because then both of you could maybe get
it one of you might have it one of you
might not he's not taking the test
himself even if you get it you can
hardly walk upstairs when you have the
lung damage going on like yeah let alone
you're gonna [ __ ] that's it's not gonna
happen you know they're just quarantined
to be away from that one friend who you
know if if my first tip if it says if
twice my friend test positive I will
effectively need to start 14 day
quarantine so maybe I think he thinks
he's just gonna be just fine no matter
what he's not gonna be sick it's gonna
be totally not a problem for him Khan do
likes it's the end of the world BIGBANG
quarantine you know they actually did
outlaw orgies in Italy did they yeah
they had they had to put on a
declaration that orgies were not allowed
to have too many too many people getting
together that's a devastating blow the
Sam's card is also useless if your
quarantine you [ __ ] idiot
I just he had to have someone reply at
the exact right time who was also trying
to quarantine risk both of them getting
sick also okay we've not even gotten to
the most dramatic part of this okay this
dude is proposing that he is locked
indoors with someone he doesn't know for
14 days that can be strangest very bad
or pretty bad I don't think they get
married but it's yeah I I feel like okay
okay so hit in his mind is he did he
specify that he's looking for a woman
yeah he did okay
he said normal healthy fun
age-appropriate sexy female with his
ages risk yeah I mean only if you're
another 60 year old no no you wouldn't
want to take that risk you wouldn't want
to do it it's not it's not worth the
risk but you got stuck in an apartment
like in his head I think he's like we're
just gonna [ __ ] it's just gonna be sex
the whole time but there are periods
after the sex in which you must talk
what if you hate each other day one you
find out this person is a flaming racist
that we did talk about how earlier you
know we might might have been off before
we were recording about I mentioned that
in China after you know since things are
starting to go down that apparently
there was a big there was a bit of a
spike in divorces in China after the
quarantine right not a good idea oh I
don't recommend it at all if you could
be stuck in quarantine with one
celebrity who would it be uh well I was
gonna say Tom Hanks but you know not a
good idea now
ah did you see how much better mind he
uses Ross that's it's yeah it was that's
too much upset me kept telling me I was
honest Rayleigh and I was like you're
honest it's too much [ __ ] regiment
III I like it lightly on my toes
supposed to have some cheese the rolls
I don't ok celebrity celebrity ah man
come on I think no I think I would go
with Chrissy Teigen because she seems
really funny and wholesome can I be
quarantined in her house sure take it
yep you know what I I would I would do I
would have little Dickey because I think
he'd make me laugh and maybe in that
time I could take up a hobby like trying
to learn yeah yeah no I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say someone that probably doesn't
use their house so I don't have to see
them cause he stole off jay-z and
Beyonce wasn't yeah that's yeah
Hollywood Hills I think maybe he'll
somewhere I house but I did some of his
parties back when he held parties yeah I
went to the the housewarming party and
that was a lot of it's a lot of house
all right Dickey we're hanging out you
can you can look it up on Google Maps
and see exactly I don't really like he
doesn't like your area sorry man shows
good this is a cool thing if you're in
New York or Los Angeles a website that
is called here slash now is offering
virtual mixes of ten people at a time
throughout March we will curate the
group invite everyone to set the vibe in
their own living room for example light
a candle and pull themselves a drink
have a host present to guide the
experience put people into a series of
short one-on-one conversations to get to
know each other better
I think that's kind of cool they saw
like weird omegle it's curated and
hosted and you get yourself a glass of
wine and maybe less dicks no way to
guarantee that
yeah that actually kind of rules
afterwards will help connect anyone who
felt a mutual Spock so they can keep the
virtual hangs until they're able to meet
IRL once again I hope this one some nice
old love stories yeah it's probably
gonna be a lot of dicks yes yeah I guess
we'll find out I'll let you know see
what happens